I don't like YouTube's new live stream
feature having said that how's
everybody's morning coming along like
how's everybody's morning cranking along
I've i'm vaping on some juice called the
player which is what is this is there
still juice in here oh hells bells
that's the wrong one what am i doing
I've lost my mind that's where to god
I'm losing my marbles um you look like
you've lost weight I appreciate it I
feel like I've lost hey what brand of
coffee you drink i'm actually not
drinking coffee today today i'm drinking
monster energy doing i doing monster
energy drink I told you guys like I got
I got hooked on that stuff its bidding
in the chat it's Benny harassing my
thing there is I got hooked on my
monster energy drink when i was in
dallas with with benny and Drake and I
just sort of like hey I've been like
hammering this stuff down now and it's
absolutely it's absolutely nuts but um
anyway it's 436 p.m. where you're at Wow
sanity is overrated yes it is yes it is
I would like to report a crime bidding
his hijacked your stream bidding his
bidding is totally had hijacked my
stream it's it you know Benny does that
mean he's been he's like hey I'm just
gonna show up and steal all the
attention cuz you know I'm Benny and
that's what I do it's funny to me it's
kind of funny um what do I talk about
your mom now I talk about your momma um
have i seen straight out of Compton no I
have not seen Straight Outta Compton um
I thought about going to see it but you
know I was not really a big fan of like
the underground you know hip-hop
movement in in the 1990s really I don't
even listen to hip hop back then yeah I
was just kind of how was listen to like
pop culture stuff like I was listen I
was listening to oh baby baby why don't
we just day together like I was listen
to that like and I was really really
psyched about it greetings from
Australia what's up
on all right why are you guys are going
to talk about mlpfim comics no idea what
that is but I know I have no idea what
that is look God man Vinny is so
hijacking my my live stream do you play
guitar if so are you any good no the
guitar is strictly just to get chicks
and it actually works so any of you guys
who are curious about how to pick up the
ladies just um tell them you have a
guitar and then just make some sounds
like just kind of strum on it and make
some sounds and then that's it and I'm
one hundred percent serious like I'm not
joking with you guys it works like it's
it's weird you know what are you a pita
day I got some sherbert juice i'm vaping
the player what do you think of we are
Robin I think we are Robin as a cool
concept I was a little a little hesitant
about it I was a little skeptical
initially I didn't know how I felt about
a series that was based strictly a round
robin and i read like issue number one
um it wasn't really enough to get me
into what in the hell mini hello Benny
I'm doing pretty good why are you
calling me on board you done workin on a
script for DC you in the new 52 man like
it's it's weird and i just finished sick
of worst part 5 i'm so psyched what are
you gonna say about DC you they started
over okay basically yeah like it's it's
like they have the they had they had
crisis on Infinite Earths because their
entire continuity was a mess and then
they been they ran into the same problem
30 years later with the new 52 and they
said you know what we're just gonna go
back and do our thing again so anyway
why are you calling me in the middle my
livestream I'm bored I'm sure do a
Supergirl video about the TV show and
I'm like haha yeah well have fun with
that because the TV shows bored you
cannot say that yes I can because I can
say from the one of us what did I sell
in a country where everything on CTV
something I'm not only I've also got to
cover once upon a time that one on I
look important yeah have fun with that
i'm doing a video on Rob explains what
would happen if a planet could crash
into us what happened to Rob explained
that was gonna call you out for on the
stream but said you bros dude I've been
focusing on my channel for the last
three weeks Rob explains as a secondary
thing that gets on occasion in your
channel yeah but like how much explained
is more important because that's my
source of income that one's more
important than Rob explains it's no damn
good don't want you to talk about we are
robbing here I'll help you up you don't
see how that come off until I get so I
get bored I read issue number in a
shimmer one of your ironing it's that
question somebody asking about it I
think it's a cool concept of having like
more than one Robin look like a bunch of
Robins but I don't know there's why why
bin has a sexy voice oh you they're
talking about your sexy voice it's
custom whispering right now this this is
my sexy voice I also use this as my
Batman voice in the bitterest it's
fantastic for worse than Batman and
Robin yes it is a hundred times worse
think of Batman and Robin Robin had camp
to it that's a made it good yeah it was
designed to be bad why are you talking
so quiet cuz my wife sleeping in 70 yeah
that's true did you what did you wake up
especially for my livestream I feel so
special actually I did my phone pinged
on your first one that has that's dead
yeah I i streamed that one by accident I
didn't mean to that was the group yeah
and I was like oh coo coo father Rob
yeah I was like I didn't mean to do that
and it you know but it's whatever um
will you review the sequel for a
fantastic 40 has a 17 if it ever comes
out no well are we all ready dude if
it'll I get me a bunch of views where I
just rail on it cuz I can guarantee you
it's gonna suck it's not gonna be good
well I just gonna miss smartest city
i've ever seen cuz we were all like what
are we gonna do for Fantastic Four you
like I'll to top five things that made
it suck yeah top five things are made to
suck what do you think of Secret Wars
number five I thought it was kind of
superfluous to overall story molecule
man covered in New Avengers do super
Wars number five is the most important
story is the most important party
circuit war so far they establish so
many things I talk about how the
beyonders got destroyed they basically
say that dr. doom see here's the here's
here's my thought for all you guys in
the chat I don't think that these
realities were actual realities when dr.
doom grabbed him I think he made them
and I think he made them when he was
going around killing all the molecule
man from the alternate realities and he
was he was basically doing it
of memory like that's my thought because
there's a point in the comic when the
Future Foundation is like everything in
existence on battle world is composed of
this energy which is like the beyond our
energy like we're made of it
everything's made of it and so if
they're made of beyond or energy who
would make sense a day that they're
basically made by dr. doom I don't know
but the other cool thing too is that the
Phoenix force is dead like Scott Summers
is dead so that means the Phoenix force
needs a new host and so my question is
are we going to see like a phoenix
powered Franklin Richards at the end of
sigit wars I think we will and I think
it's going to be awesome I did not go to
d23 i wish i had though because i leaked
the civil war footage there and I can't
believe him till I comes out do we
really should honestly you and I just
pretty much look for any reason to flag
drop the states and pretty much a black
widow a double agent for civil war I i
guess but that beacon in a psych ward I
want to ask you something that about
because you said to get worse five he
feels probably were the best ones uh-huh
did do you not the Kate in my opinion it
while is good for anyone who hasn't been
reading Avengers and stuff it's it's
kind of pointless people like you and me
who have been reading up in your system
because it was a lot a lot of rehab yeah
but if you look past that there's a lot
of important stuff too like we more
Appeals a couple things yeah I'll give
you that Mike we know Franklin Richards
will fight doom at the end of the series
we know that rugged at the end of Secret
Wars I mean we know that we know how it
was like we didn't know like up into
this point we didn't know what happened
that led to doom and strange and well
that was a kicker apparently doom what
doom wasn't there Doctor Strange wasn't
there and only molecule man Owen Reese
was there not only that if you look at
what molecule man Owen Reese was saying
Hickman is I don't know if he's actually
gonna do it or not or if I'm almost
gonna do it but he's basically setting
the stage for molecule man being the new
Galactus so ya know it I do do you find
it weird that Marvel has recently been
putting a lot of focus on people that
know and care about d or molecule man no
molecule man was important for the story
and that makes sense to me but I mean
he's not I mean this is the first time
we've seen him since secret war started
and were three issues away from the
series ending so I'm think they're
focusing on him on people that don't
matter but the orb yeah I get that but I
think the reason why they out of the or
ban is because they were I think they
knew what they wanted to do is
secret wars they were just kind of
putting stuff in until they got there
they were just like this is make stories
until we get there until they had it
worked out Talia dawn are dying i prime
mispronounced it wants to know doesn't
care about what you think of us of or
they would like to know what you think
about finding dory I haven't seen I
haven't seen fun it's finding Dory out
yet no I they previewed it also guy
there along with the new Star Wars stuff
um I am so gonna go see finding dory hey
Rob why he's Nemo's I'm Anna technically
advanced Jess you next question just go
with the defining dory first then I am
so gonna go check out cuz funny Nemo was
amazing like I think finding Dory would
be really cool you gotta fly here will
seat here and then I'll fly to you for
lunch and obviously I'll see Kentucky
bending their Kentucky sucks like you
don't want to fly out here this place
sucks um Drake came here for one day and
said he's moving here like officially
like he's legitimately trying to find a
house are you serious yeah dude I gotta
come out there invisible i do want to
come out there and visit for your 24
hour livestream okay so what was the
other question um why do you think what
Conda so technologically advanced oh
because of vibranium like they
established that in the early stories of
of marble comics where they said that
because of the fact of vibranium is like
the rarest source on earth and what
Conda owns the entire store of it that
there does they use it they sell it for
technology i guess for for money
whatever the case may be but because of
the fact that that black panthers
inherently intelligent too like he's
like a fourth smartest person or second
smartest person on the planet or
something like that like it's weird he's
he's in the top five but okay um what do
you think about Incredibles to being
announced ah I wasn't a big fan of the
first Incredibles what yeah I don't know
one harness channel down I know I know I
know I know that wasn't a big fan of the
first Incredibles here's a good one for
you because you do a lot more of this
live sheep stuff than I do any advice
for starting a podcast ooh have been
easy ice for one because your voice
sounds amazing but uh but no i don't i
mean advice for starting a podcast I
mean I just get on here and just talked
to people so I think it's much I think
it's tougher to do a podcast and it is
to do like a live stream Q&A now do they
mean podcast podcast or they didn't mean
like youtube channel podcasts
they just said how to start a podcast I
don't specify I mean pick a topic that
you like and see if you can talk about
it for an hour and if you can upload it
no he people trying that some of them
work sounded out some of them don't um
are you reading the new civil war I know
I had no interest in reading the new
civil war and actually really good i'm
liking alive you see the problem that I
have is I mean I read the what if story
on Civil War what if Civil War never
ended I read the what if story what if
the roles are reversed I read you know
of course the main some more okay what's
what do you like about this currents of
work here's a question for you I like
the concept of the fight continuing but
being in a totally separate world so we
have a divided us by them you know like
the fight because what this shows is the
fight escalated to a point where they've
divided everything like that and that
shows that that could have happened if
Captain America didn't step down yeah I
don't know I'm not really sure i don't
like them turning spider-man into Falcon
though I really turned spider-man no
Falcon basically they gave him the
Falcon wings and everything is Captain
America's right-hand man and that sucks
what is your opinion on Blue's Clues Oh
Blue's Clues yes Blue's Clues is awesome
dude in the corner is jacking it yahudi
having a corner of your house robbed a
duty is jacking it do you think Black
Panther could be the MCU version of Reed
Richards and being a business for
December yes and I think that's
explicitly why he was introduced because
I don't let me tell you something
Fantastic Four was terrible but Fox and
given those rights back if Fox was going
to make a movie like that there's no way
they're going to give the rights back so
the Fantastic Four is pretty much gone
from the marvel cinematic universe
unless something happens some miracle
unless Jesus comes down and persuades
Fox to give the rights back to the
Marvel like this it's never going to
happen and so introducing Black Panther
n as the smartest person on earth
basically makes him puts them in the
role of Reed Richards that's what makes
it straight ok which non comic book
characters do you think would work
perfect for comic books DC or marvel
which non comic book characters mmm
which nod comic book characters would
work best for DC or marvel Sherlock
Holmes not stealing a Rob from you guys
I'm asking your daughter that's all that
I'll go if you want known or felt
himself you're fine you're fun um no I
think Sherlock Holmes would be an
awesome character to add in only because
it'd be interesting to see how a person
that has that's that's super smart you
know it's like a private investigator
what function in a world of superheroes
like Sherlock Holmes who has no
superpowers who is just really good at
deducing facts I mean it's just a really
good investigator he's not like it like
the smartest man ever you know like how
he would function in trying to track
down some money they can make themselves
invisible or something like that like
it'd be a really cool I think it'd be
really cool story okay someone said yogi
bear what do you go to you giggling
about no I'm not I'm trying to saturate
the wicked I'm watching the video still
so it's crazy too late so that's noise
matched up to you laughing that's it
that's a weird laugh like are you like
just turned into easy now um play
something guitar and now you say no to
that I so a couple you love asked how I
what's going on to Jim how's it working
that way it's gone along fine I switch I
mean I switched over like I was doing a
workout like i was doing for for
movement work out where it was it was
monday wednesdays and fridays i haven't
done it for like two months it was
monday wednesdays and fridays it was
arms back curls and then anyway i'll
choose days and three nights it was it
was it was upper body and lower body
more or less and it was six days a week
and then i transitioned off that and I
actually stole like the rocks workout
for Hercules and I do that five days a
week and it's [ __ ] tough like I do
one of the workouts that I do is a
flatbed cable pool so like I literally
just like pull the cables into my chest
it's almost like doing dumbbell flyes
except you're using cables and it
it's so sore ya know I started doing
some crazy or [ __ ] like look just do it
increasing a lot of the weight mm-hmm
I'm doing a lot like yeah you know for
the record they have said it and I do
agree you are looking really good yay
Thank You Benny I appreciate it man so
you've gotten a couple questions about
Metal Gear Solid are you ever
considering explaining video games uh
never really gave it too much thought
before but i love the Metal Gear Solid
series so I'd be funny where you do it I
tried it two years ago i'm not i'm not
trying to come up myself at all because
it's horrendous like it's called like if
you ever want to see like like if you go
into it perhaps earliest videos like he
doesn't have scrolling perks and stuff
if you want to see my earliest videos
how come comics dorian launch with like
a plan in place it's cuz if you could
look at my old metal gear solid it's
horrible dude well that's interesting
like it's like an anti plug don't go
look for don't go look for well you know
they're gonna go look for it now it's
not too hard to find if you look at if
you look a metal gear solid story it
comes up and that's who the annoying
part cuz all i get is people trashing on
it and I'm like it's three years old
anyway that's me but back to you this
episode of comics and coffee is brought
to you by comics Torian TV here yeah
make sure you check out comic story TV
this episode is brought to you by a
three year three year old series that he
did on his gaming channel Shh man um how
do you feel about egg salad that sounds
like fun uh ma'am I could take egg salad
the way I can take my friend Dustin
small doses like moments as time do
Dustin is manned us as a cool guy but
the problem is the problem is this I'll
go over to a friend's house and Destin
will be there or we'll go out and we'll
get a beer or something like that right
and dozen will say what's your take on
this particular subject and no matter
what answer I give him he takes the
opposite stance and then the argument
never ends like like it'll be two hours
later he'd be like by the way one thing
i want to remind you of and it'll go
along with the damn argument again and
it's always one of the bellies people
like the argument can't did not Kent to
I until you say okay you wait and go
away yeah exactly but I've known since
high school so you know I can't hate on
and I hate people like that
bramall call me up at weird hours just
to argue guess he finds it funny it's
just what are you talking about you you
their menu you're making stuff up now
I'd never make stuff up I'm always true
all right of course um what nod comic
related YouTube channels do you watch
that's a good that is a good one the
record guys we're trying to avoid the
questions that I know I've seen any in
here before cuz I do watch his
colleagues and coffee thing um the loyal
patriot has let me tell you something
for those of you guys who think my voice
is amazing you guys need to check out a
little patron he's got the best voice on
the planet it's like deep and smooth
it's amazing um the mark of J who has a
has a call of duty channel only one
gamer does MINECRAFT seananners I
watched him hutch i watch occasionally
like a lot of it sold call duty gamers
that have transitioned her channels over
um I used to watch a booty sweet back in
the day but he lost his mind and stopped
I can't lost his mind oh just like an
octonaut yeah he loves it loves his mind
uh yeah i mean it's it's a handful you
know stuff like that Tyrone Magnus he
has really good reaction videos yeah
just stuff like that all right um no not
asking any of that I'm sure you're
seeing the same ones I am yes I am yes I
am I thought I had a black list all but
I guess maybe I don't know where that
one came up is like a weird in place yes
what is your favorite coffee ooh cuz you
do drink coffee yeah you do yeah drink
coffee call Commerce see it's actually
it's the live stream called comics and
coffee that I've had coffee on maybe
four times well it's like Dodger does
that whole coffee time and I think she I
think mostly she drinks tea yeah like
it's weird um my favorite coffee is the
house blend from starbucks it's it's
pretty damn good that is a good one
mm-hmm what the WTF live YouTube ads
it's new three years ago live YouTube
what's going on
it's weird you don't know one punch man
do you know these is a manga guy i'm
just all good that myself hmm you think
Rob rant cuz you got I don't know yet
but just a lot of weird questions I mean
it's it's it's how do you how do I feel
about weed all right here you go guys
here's my stance on topics like that I
recognized her as an inherent danger
with doing things that cause a mental
impairment but I also recognize that has
to be balanced with the fact that people
should be able to make their own choices
and should be able to decide what they
do and don't put into their own bodies
having said that I treated like alcohol
we don't arrest people for drinking
alcohol but we arrest people for driving
under the intoxication of alcohol we
arrest them for being intoxicated by
alcohol when they're out in public you
know treat it that way you know
regulated you know give people the right
to decide what they want to put in their
bodies just make sure they don't become
a danger to society that's my stance on
things like that so 100 I got an email
uh all right since Minnie's apparently
vacated a comic story explained you must
do a video we must do a video where did
he go Benny are you even there bene all
right apparently but he's gone let's see
if you were to have a lantern ring which
one would you have even though scroll
back up even though the Rings would have
to come to you okay if I could have a
lantern room which one when i pick mmm
see i'm inclined to say green because it
greens the launch huh go orange I don't
want to have a lantern ring of greed
hell but see if you get control of it
like Larfleeze has for the most part you
get to control an entire arm yeah and I
guess I'm the only one that can have
that ring uh no and for the record be I
stepped up for a second to PA know how
long you ran for oh ok I was like we're
gonna go you're just you're just gone
and I know cuz you were going on and I'm
trying not to like to interrupt and I
could take over your stream I'm trying
to help you know yeah it's not a problem
um hmm i would say i'd probably go i
would i would go with the green lantern
ring because i think it's the most
balanced I mean that's one where you
don't like all you need is a little
power like you don't need like an
external force to allow you to use your
ring that's weird yeah I honestly I
would go sphere shift course you would
want because it's be terrified of it no
no the reason is that they've proven in
multiple comics that you don't have to
be evil to have the yellow ring and then
you don't have any of the constraints
that come along with the green ring but
you get all the powers of a yellow rent
of a green ring yeah that's good point
it's not like putting on a red one where
turned you into like an evil guy or you
know a yeah or as a side effect agreed
yellows entire lip to you see I'd like I
like the idea of the Red Lantern Corps
and like the red ring issues I don't
want to die if i take it off so it is
giving blood I don't wanna be spewing
blood that eats people skin like I don't
want to do that that would perceive Reds
my favorite too but I'm in the exact
same but I'm like I don't want this to
be the end of me people are asking if
you have washed your hands yes I washed
me what's up he's an ex-military guy of
course you watch the same nice actually
when I cuz I did I was a ranger for the
first five years but the last for 25
years I was preventive medicine so I
literally talked classes on how to wash
your hands because nobody knows how to
wash their hands really like you put
them under water and then you put soap
on them yeah I'd have to give a 30
minute class and how that happens and
the new lie rub your hands together
lemon okay if you need it if you need to
be taught on how to wash your hands we
got bigger problems going on why do you
buddy why do you think it's a lot of
dumb people in the army I mean I was in
the Army there's a lot of dumb people oh
my god what if Lobo got a lamp didlo
original everybody's I'm gonna hijack
your scene for one second to tell you
what the dumbest guy I ever met the
military okay so they have this test you
take to get in it goes from 0 to 100
it's kinda like nsit to see where you
can qualify in pressing myself I got a
91 on it I didn't get it I didn't get
400 I'm not gonna I'm not gonna fake it
but I met a guy in because in order to
become rain chip to go through efforts
you training first so on temperature
training and one of the guys in there
was so proud if you
21like he beat out his brothers and his
sisters and he totally topped everyone
and he was walking around the baby in LA
I got 21 there's some deep Louisiana and
apparently I don't know he was lying it
out but he used like push boats to get
to the main road so you can go to school
Wow and he would just tell the most like
and at first she would think it's a joke
but he would tell stories that no normal
human being would ever tell why Wow
Jesus what happened after house of him
and where can you read it after half two
of them became decimation and estimation
was the reason why the mutants were not
involved in civil war after that
everything just kind of merges into
Secret Invasion that's the difference
guys those of you who are curious so I'm
not sure why you would be reading it at
this point but for those of you who are
curious you had the mutants and you had
the extra yeah you have the X min and
you have the the Avengers and so on they
kind of existed as a cohesive unit that
would occasionally crossover up until
you got to the house of em then they
split off the Avengers did civil war the
mutant stood decimation and they merge
back in together again with with Secret
Invasion that's kind of how that weird
fork comes in that's how that that
circle gets squared or whatever the
phrase is I have no idea what that
phrases I got one for a that came up but
I don't know if you can do it because i
know i do know you watch one but i know
if you watch other can you compare and
contrast Star Wars and Star Trek oh do
not watch them both religiously same
pair in contrast Star Wars and Star Trek
will see this is a kicker because a lot
of people talk about how amazing Star
Trek was Star Trek was basically a
dystopian not really dystopian but it
was a futuristic like Marxist
militaristic society like it was a
society where people existed for the
greater good but you still had some kind
of a government so I guess maybe it had
Vanguard attributes but it was basically
like a highly militaristic society that
just happened to be explorers like
that's basically the way it was star
star wars is the Star Wars is amazing so
here's here's a question I would ask
we're the Sith wrong in Star Wars they
brought peace of the galaxy when I
accept that zipper right yeah I said
right to your problem i have with the
Star Wars myself I don't know if you
agree on this or not but I feel like the
Jedi miss it are too far to both
extremes it's like playing a video game
and they
a moral choice of renegade shepard or
more good shepherd and you're either
going to like sacrifice your life for a
cup of coffee or you're going to burn
down an orphanage like they're two
streams well yeah that was a problem
like that was that was a funny that's
why I if you it sucks that it doesn't he
got really expanded universe but the
expanded universe had a lot of really
cool scenarios where you would have
people that would pop up like like
people say for example the problem with
the with the Jedi the reason why the
Jedi Civil were not the Jedi Civil War
the the hyperspace war happened was
because the Jedi were just complacent
like the Jedi kind of cast the syph out
they cast out like Jedi the fell to the
dark side they cast them out rather than
trying to rehabilitate them rather than
trying to figure out why they left they
just somebody said get out of here and
then those dark jedi joined the actual
race of the Sith and that's the Sith
were born and so it's a really cool
concept once you get into all those
different things but if you're talking
about just like the basic interest that
I have in them I would say that I think
that that Star Wars is a lot more
entertaining than Star Trek Star Trek's
awesome you know I think it has some
cool attributes but I think that when
you look at the entire expanded universe
of Star Wars is far more immersive than
Star Trek but you know see I will cuz
I've read a lot of the extra stuff I
will disagree with a level at Star Trek
but but in the flip side I feel like
Star Trek because of their rules
regulations in the Federation is a
little more restricted than what Star
Wars can do co star wars can just do
whatever the hell they want in space and
just make it up yeah pretty much while
everything for Star Trek has to conform
to what's already there yeah yeah it's
pretty well coffee is amazing it
deserves absolute devotion yes it does
yes it does I agree thoughts on Jim
Gordon Batman I think Jim Gordon Batman
we need to do a video about that I think
Jim Gordon Batman I knew his lab on that
we should both feel I think you were in
Batman is one of the best things to ever
happen to the Batman story here's why
guys Bruce Wayne is an icon of the
Batman series I mean he is Batman he's
been Batman since he was first
introduced a detective comics issue
number whatever in 1940 the problem with
Bruce Wayne is this there's nothing he
can't do like no matter what scenario
Bruce Wayne is thrown into he always
finds some way to figure it out with Jim
Gordon he's literally flying by the seat
of his pants
like he's just in a Batman suit and he's
just kind of doing what he can and
hoping it works out and really just kind
of taking things as they go he doesn't
have the intellect he doesn't have the
resources he doesn't have a skill set of
Batman you know I mean he doesn't he
doesn't have the backing of billions of
dollars in the super intellect and all
the technology that comes with it and
the ability to manipulate stuff and
knowing how these villains function on a
personal level because he hasn't been
fighting them day in and day out for
decades and decades you know Bruce Wayne
has and so I think that to take a
character and just interject him into
that scenario and say suddenly you're
Batman is a cool concept and reading the
stories that comes out and it is amazing
what you could all go down like I really
love it so anyway I actually heard a
really good point of that actually I
think goes movie about the dinner on
screw another screw tech shows but I
made a video explaining that Bruce
Wayne's just a jerk now no because well
in order to make him function with the
rest of the Justice League they've
increased his fortune to points where
he's not just a guy with a large trust
fund he can literally buy the world so
the question becomes why is he getting
into a bad suit and spending money all
this stuff to go beat up on thugs when
at his level of money he should know
that if you just create jobs and you
know fix up the streets themselves then
you'll actually eliminate crime in that
manner and why isn't he spending his
money in that way it what it comes down
to is he's just a rich boy who wants to
go beat up a poor people that is a
really that is a really good point like
that's that's a real like use your money
to decrease crime don't beat up
criminals exactly and it's proven a lot
of times a badman isn't that the
criminals are just poor people trying to
get by because they have no money and
this is the only thing they can do and
Bruce Wayne is jumping in there and
punching them with these like insanely
high tech gadgets like you oh my god
what's your opinion on Ben Affleck
directing the next Batman trilogy I'm
actually really hyped guys and this is I
think is a source of contention because
people look at Ben Affleck and they look
at one or two stories and they were one
of your movies and they say oh my god
Ben Affleck's going to suck and I
disagree you know because if you look at
that athlete from the time he first
showed up in Hollywood up until now he's
done nothing but getting but got better
like he's done nothing I'm I have the
script already and sig awards number
five will hopefully be up later on today
or maybe tomorrow um but he's done
nothing but get better over the years
with his acting and with his directing
having said that he's got the entire
catalogue of Batman films to work with i
mean the problem was when Michael Keaton
first showed up there really were no
Batman films when you had George Clooney
he was during the era where Batman
Batman films were designed to be campy
they weren't designed to be taken
seriously and so when you look at things
now you've got Christopher Nolan's
Batman you've got you know the entire
Michael Keaton Batman Batman Returns
you've got you know Batman and Robin
you've got all kinds of stuff to him to
look at you've got all the comics and
everything and with this age with this
this era being what it is in terms of
more serious coming book characters in
terms of sometimes darker comic book
characters there is a there's a market
for creating a realistic dark and gritty
Bruce Wayne and I think that Ben Affleck
can pull that off but it depends I mean
this movie Batman vs Superman will set
the stage for the kind of Batman that
we'll see in Ben Affleck's films and so
if he comes out and he's just kind of
silly no one's going to take it
seriously but if he comes out and he is
hardcore if he comes out and he's
basically Bruce Wayne from the dark
knight returns or even the new 52 to a
degree like it'll be a very promising
trilogy of films at least I'll be
excited to go see him so we'll see
what's up well i'm still here by the way
i am still trying to do my supergirl
thing well okay are you seriously going
through Supergirl I'm just putting up a
like what why what what do we know about
it like what characters right now okay
what what do you feel about a how do you
feel about you don't watch doctor who do
you know I don't watch enough dude okay
someone asks how you feel about Peter
book called Paul day neither i'll talk
about dr who that's why i was now i've
never watched dr. view Nova Corps versus
the Green Lantern Corps that's a good
vs.
Green Lantern Corps hands down like
there's no there's no contesting there
okay and here's a reason why guys
there's there's no there's no debate
there and here's a reason why the Nova
Corps has the ability to manipulate the
Nova force but the Nova horse has its
limits it's just a huge source of energy
the problem here is they can't
manipulate it for any effect they can
just kind of disperse concussive blasts
of energy and stuff like that the Green
Lantern Corps can use their rings to
create anything I mean anything their
minds can imagine and really I mean how
you would really need is just like an
army of of oh god man I keep one to
think Ray Palmer but it's not very
Palmer House bills what's uh he was I on
he was no then he helped me out here I
if it's not what do you mean ready Tala
the great though the most imaginative
Green Lantern what was his name Howard
Howe Raynor yes Keller okay okay i can't
i can't think in Ray Palmer like I had
repo murs not that's gonna say if you're
asking me to remember the names of
conventions that aren't the for
earthlings you're under oh no I okay um
but no no so that's all you would need
like an army of him but but no I would
say that at the end of the day it would
come down like the Green Lantern's could
probably take it I mean yeah that's a
car alarm going off like somebody
there's a car when Carl on going off in
the background outside in the apartment
complex it's a pain who's your favorite
Robin oh god my favorite Robins Dick
Grayson and here's why Dick Grayson is a
great legacy character i think damian
Wayne's more dynamic and i think damian
wayne is more intriguing on a personal
level because he's literally a kid like
Damian Wayne is a really great character
here's my Damian Wayne's a great
character I don't think he's better to
them better than Dick Grayson but here's
why he's a great character Damian Wayne
is a kid that is simultaneously trying
to struggle with the idea that Bruce
Wayne was never in his life trying to
accept Bruce Wayne as a father figure
but at the same time sees Bruce Wayne
through the eyes that he was taught to
see a man by his mom you know in the
sense that he's just like you know I
hate Bruce Wayne you know I hate what he
stands for I'm all down for killing
people saw him because Bruce Wayne is
the antithesis to Damian Wayne Damian
Wayne and Bruce Wayne have similar ideas
but Damien Wayne's willing to kill where
Bruce Wayne's not and so I think that
that for Damian to struggle with all
those things at the same time being such
a dark kid who in truth you know
shouldn't be shouldn't had that kind of
a mindset you know to effectively been
raised as an assassin I think makes her
it makes for him being more dynamic
having said that did grace and i think
is more important because of that dick
grayson that never would have been a
Damien in the first place you know or
Robin or anything like that and I think
that dick Grayson's set the standard for
superheroes and so on and so forth and
what I decide you know what characters I
prefer i usually go by legacy what do
they do for the industry and I think
Dick Grayson did more for the comic book
industry than any other Robin this ever
been in existence so but don't you like
Dick Grayson moving on to become
Nightwing it's tough oh yeah it's cool
I'm just saying in terms of all the
people who have played rock James Bond
educate you and James Bond nocturnal
wish what's up so I said wave if you see
this James Bond vs. Jason Bourne Jason
Bourne yes Jason Bourne any day the week
Uncle Ben could defeat Thanos no no like
not not by a long shot would you see a
Harley Quinn TV series oh yeah like a
Harlequin solo series definitely i'd be
excited to see that I mean I think it
depends on who's playing it but I'd be
pretty excited to see that what
monitored you I use I use an asus 27
inch monitor that's pretty badass it's
pretty glowy to have you ever seen a
night just glows like it almost gives
them a suntan but you never tell yeah it
takes me eight hours to sunburn believe
it or not I guess it's weird how strong
is Martian Manhunter I would argue that
Martian Manhunter emitting a probably
argue better than I can but I would
argue that Martian Manhunter is on par
if not stronger than Superman um I don't
know him that well but I know that every
time he's been brought up that's the
claim but it seems like every time he's
like I'm stronger than Superman to
Superman pummels him so I mean he could
make himself intangible so and in that
that's the big weakness and that the
shape-shifting is another big one yeah
like that so that's one question of what
use
your ability to pull planets if you
can't hit the guy that you're fighting
so I don't know thank you for answering
my question Rob cheers is it always
amazes me like this this is a QA and
people are like probably answered my
question well of course I did is a Q&A
it's like the people that when I go
respond to comments my favorite is when
someone cuz if you're a troll sometimes
you'll get me a little riled up but i'll
just give you the reason why it did
something i don't ever fight back i just
get my reasons but a lot of times if
someone puts a legit criticism i will
respond to it and it's funny because if
i respond to it they run away delete the
comma what should be the next model
property to enter the MCU the century
Robert Reynolds like hands yes you ever
do that cuz no Superman no it just neat
well yeah I get that people will say
that but it just it needs to be like or
just do it in netflix just do like like
a scene just say they took superman
because not enough people know who sent
tree is then the hurt to stand off as I
oh this was this is his own character
he's not a super my clone yeah I know
but this is the world according to rob
so i would say i would say definitely
the century rubber on Rob channel I'm
not gonna just be button but if we had
to pick a mainstream popular character
Miles Morales like Miles Morales needs
to enter the marble and it's high time
and I think that became really prevalent
when when Kenan foggy well at least when
it became public knowledge that Marvel
was getting the rights to spider-man
we're not really getting the rights
Marvel was working with Sony on
spider-man and they were talking about
rebooting it people were saying like we
need Miles Morales and I think I mean
Kevin foggy and they made their I call
know Saint Peter Parker if you're going
to introduce spider-man to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you got to go with a
familiar face and you gotta introduce
Peter Parker having said that I would
not object to seeing a Miles Morales
post I guess post infinity war you know
I wouldn't mind seeing that I think it's
I think it's time to get miles miles
into the mainstream in terms of the
movies because he's already doing well
in the comics people love him in the
comics you know and so I think it's time
to see him move forward a little bit but
I think the problem with Miles Morales
is that they're scared that bad class
they got when they first introduced and
it took almost like three years I'm to
be actually accepted yeah but in this
day and age I mean
think that it but see was it was I mean
it was hardcore how many book fans that
were freaking out because they killed
their own his daughter freak out oh yeah
they are always on the freak out but
they killed the kill Peter Parker which
it makes sense we don't need two
versions of Peter Parker like we got
Peter Parker and we've had him for last
was like well I want both well you know
you can't have both so I think it was a
good idea to kill him off or replace him
in Miles Morales and I think that was
that was most of the backlash as fans
were mad because Peter Parker was dead
but no I think I mean I think right now
fans are ready to see it i think the
general public wouldn't oppose it you
know i mean i think it'd be fun to get
with moss Bareilles i do agree with you
i think the people are becoming more
accepting of things getting change in
the movies but I mean they're still very
much against thing changing in the
comics female towards the point of that
yeah oh my god that back like she's led
by the way oh do they it amazes my
question yeah it amazes me how how
people got so bent out of shape over
that would you want to play in the MCU
or the DC you mean like which one when I
choose to exist in if I had to choose if
I had to choose between existing and the
dcu or the MCU i would say that DC you
like I would choose to exist in the DC
Cinematic Universe because I think it is
I think characters like Batman and
Superman are more intriguing than a lot
of characters and models line up but you
know Marvel's more established they have
more going on I don't know I wouldn't
use the term established but that you
already do it the more going on you it's
always been that debate of this rob its
DC's a world of gods like that people
above the normal man while Marvel's
characters are all trying to be the
normal man yeah I would agree with then
I think it's a good call I don't know
what's your favorite form of transport
driving I mean I Drive everywhere I go
should help you yeah well I mean I do my
cardio with the gym I bike and skate boy
every were like a kid well that's cool
Benny that's cool awesome free Mesa
skated it to the comic book shop like
than the guy in areas like really really
you're gonna skateboard over here say
how old is it
like Benny and Rob what's your
definition of a superhero that's a good
question someone who is selfless uh no
you don't need power than that in my
opinion is someone who's willing to
sacrifice himself with the greater good
I'd say it's somebody that's willing to
kill people so the punisher is a Desilu
just wanted to say I just want to say
the furniture I just wanted an excuse to
say the punisher what makes a good
superhero um well I mean of course I
think having having abilities is what
what makes somebody a superhero I mean I
think I think that's like a definitive
factor you know definitive difference
between like The Punisher and say
captain america having said that mmm or
you don't that I got a question for you
okay oh uh I think that that knowing the
difference when to run away and like
knowing the difference like when to
fight is an important attribute because
I think that one of the bigger bigger
issues that a lot of heroes have and one
of the things they kind of drives me
nuts sometimes is they'll just go
headlong into a conflict and just keep
on fighting until they win you know and
as Jack Sparrow once said you know we
have to fight in order to run away I
died in the DC you know I wouldn't I
would not die in the Indy see you I
guess it back I see you dying and then
you can provide nine times and you'd
come back at the Red Hood watching
dragon ball super Rob yes I am in the
last episode look like crap yeah
everyone's complaining about that
mawashi x I don't I don't have time to
watch subtitle stuff that's my issue I
don't believe it worth while watching
yeah it looks really bad so I got a
question for you and this is an honest
connection about so the video making is
a rundown of everything that happened in
Supergirl after recording me audio
putting this video together I discovered
on the wiki that there's a lot of past
announcements of characters that I
didn't get in mention so instead of
recording the audio I've put a text
overlay which is this is the full list
we didn't mention older announcements
and I just did the full list of guys and
they're on the screen while I'm
mentioning everyone you can get to work
molded I mean do the old announcements
tie into what's going on no it's just a
we just went through the list of people
who have been confirmed to show up in
the show like livewire Sam Lane
that kind of thing well I mean if the
video is based on who's showing up in
the show then that should work fine
because if I mean the old list is I
would I mean that's cool because it
comes across with the oldest thing like
it's there if you care about it but it
doesn't matter right now and if it's not
I mean if it doesn't matter there's no
point as long as it's there some could
call that what oh you forgot like people
that's kind of going for with that yeah
I mean well any of you if you add some
annotation like you know these
characters that were mentioned
previously but they're not going to be
hard of the show then I think that would
make a difference but it's not an
annotation I'm putting it as a text
overlay in the video oh ok ok yeah that
should be so no matter what device you
watch it on it's there ok uh Rob would
find the dcu dragonballz and bring
yamcha back with him yamcha whatever man
I'd give you too much I would give
vegeta lakes you know it's freezing a
girl uh mmm that's a good question but
this is actually a good question after
that answer that one first but I get
this is a good no I don't know I mean I
don't have an answer to that question I
mean nobody knows like fruits of tranza
is general neutral yeah gender neutral
there we go someone asked if you're
gonna be valiant and I was actually nice
are you going to start dipping into
other publishers because now we have
permission to them are you going to
stick with Marvel and DC uh yes I want
to dip into other publishers the first
aunt the first thing I want to do is I
want to answer the question I'm going to
talk about the community in the walking
dead because that is man that story so
good plus the walking dead comes back in
October so it'd be a really opportune
time to talk about that because I know I
know you've made the comment before like
all the other publishers don't do as
well as my normal stuff and that's that
mean that's something I run into too but
yeah yeah I always look at it as we're
here to educate that's true well that's
see I was thinking about that when I was
doing the script for for the dcu in the
new 52 is that was like okay how can I
make this make sense without being too
without being overly convoluted like
without being overly nonsense cool
because I could go all the way back to
the very beginning of everything with a
problem is it would turn into this it
would get people confused and it would
throw people off so it's like you know
make that information reasonable clear
to understand you know but make sure the
important points are touched on and and
I think that's kind of a that's kind of
a kicker the transcends over to doing
outside stuff i mean if i do anything
that's not marvel and truth on my
channel like you just won't
nearly as good as everything else but
you know that's because the audience
doesn't exist for it so the issue is
making that audience come into existence
and so you know making that you know
doing you know starting out with popular
indie titles and then working from there
I think is the key and I think the right
now when it comes to indie titles The
Walking Dead's about as popular as it
gets so well it's walking dead um saga
is pretty high up there Scott Snyder's
Rhonda is doing really well yeah Walking
Dead's pretty much up there yeah what is
your prediction on the battle world
storyline my prediction of the battle
world storyline is I don't won't matter
well I mean it's really not going to so
here's one here's what they established
in sick of wars part 5 they establish
that the that molecule man Owen Reese
dr. doom and dr. strange each existed
and served three essential purposes in
battle world molecule man served as a
conduit when dr. doom and all those guys
when I guess when dr. doom molecule man
and doctors change when they basically
killed the beyonders when the beyonders
were killed off the power of the
beyonders was too much for any one of
them to simply consume within themselves
the power would literally kill them
because it was just way too much and so
they took the power and they trapped it
in this giant metal box it was quite
literally a giant metal box molecule man
serves as a conduit so he's basically a
vector by which doom can access the
beyonders power where dr. doom could
access the power and impose his will on
battle world dr. strange was his eyes
and ears he heard everything and he saw
everything and knew everything that was
going on in battle world but because dr.
strange is dead doom doesn't have any
eyes and ears which means that people
can subvert his authority now it means
he's not going to know what's going on
he's not going to know what's taking
place because he's not all-knowing and
so what's going to end up happening is
battle worlds basically probably gonna
devolved into a state of civil war and
then what was going to use that as a
platform to launch the all new all
different Marvel by saying well battle
it's been destroyed now we have molecule
man is Galactus and we have the Phoenix
force taking over somebody and so on and
so forth and and there's going to be a
return to the status quo it's just going
to be different faces like I mean that's
that's the kicker guys let's all new all
different Marvel Universe is going to
look very similar to the old universe
it's just going to have different faces
it's going to have different people
playing different roles and that's
really it that's really going to be the
difference so I'm curious if they're
going to redo origins like when DC did
the new 52 they redid the origins to go
online with what they what they've
changed I don't know man like that's
what I've been wondering I don't think
they will to be honest because I think
if they were they would have done it
already not necessarily because think
about it I mean the whole point of this
is to make it an easier universe
understanding the problem with most of
these origins why I don't do a lot of
model origins is because they aren't
just single ones one-off stories they're
60 years of continuity have to cram into
it but the problem is none of the
stories are going on right now matter oh
yeah i'm saying when they won they
relaunch like martin a great thing of
launching putting out the books and then
they launched a separate comic called
secret origins where they actually
revealed a lot of the origins that
weren't getting revealed well plus they
had like 0 month and stuff like that
yeah yeah so that that's the capping i'm
wondering i'm wondering if as time goes
on are we going to get newer fresher
origins its characters I mean if Mara
were smart they would do that they would
say like 0 month and they would say this
month after Secret Wars this is all the
origins for the characters you know and
love like all they like all the Maine
State characters or they were just
rehash the existing origins because I
would be the smart thing to if they
chose not to eliminate the continuity if
the history of Miles Morales going into
all new all different Marvel is a
continuation from his origin and
Ultimate Universe to the end of
everything going into super [ __ ]
picking up with all new all different
Marvel then he'd be smart if they came
back and said here's the origin story of
Miles Morales covered in a single comic
from the time he first appeared in The
Ultimate Universe up until the current
moment and that would be though I guess
his words of story in The Ultimate
Universe and then spend two pages
covering the end of everything and all
that kind of stuff like that would be a
smart idea because it would give people
a place to start so yeah I don't know I
agree with you I do i think i think we
also plus my guard job so much easier
here's the new origin here's a report to
be so easy to do was like well here's
the question i asked you i tweeted this
out last night and i want to know what
your opinion because marvel's Donald
been doing a lot more in DC's now gone
online with it how do you feel about
them doing shorter story or
character-driven story arcs because
honestly it's making my job freak ton
easier instead of being six to nine ish
york's we're talking like 124 issue arcs
mm-hmm
how do you feel about that like it about
them being shorter and a lot easier to
just pick up a reading go well we talked
about their own podcast and I love that
idea like I think it's a really cool
idea because I mean because you made a
really good point you were saying that
like like DC you've been doing that for
a long time and it worked because like
fans could say well I want to read Green
Lantern I don't care about Superman I
don't care about you know Batman or
anything I just want to bring you office
want to read Green Lantern and they
could just pick up a Green Lantern comic
and they could read it you know and they
could they could start with a new story
arc they could go online and they could
just say oh ok well this new story our
picks up here and if they were curious
you know about what led into that story
awk they could look up look it up on
Wikipedia or they can come to our
channels or something like that and they
can get that information and then jump
right into the story with Marvel you
can't do that you know with Marvel it
was all about well we got Avengers vs.
x-men well I mean what's the basis for
Avengers vs. x-men well it comes out of
all this and I comes out of all that and
if they pick up a Miles Morales comic
and they see Galactus you know where you
have the event what is it ultimate not
ultimate um I came up with the name of
the event was but it was the ultimate
universe when Galactus shows up and
they're all is like oh my god wouldn't
know I was hopin it you know yeah that
was yeah that was no she's talking about
yeah it's called something yeah but like
like they're gonna be like well me I
don't know and they're like well how'd
it go like to skate here well that ties
in the age of Ultron weird age of Ultron
come from well it ties into visible and
so on and so forth and it you know it's
this ongoing series of things it just
doesn't you know you have to read one
thing after another in order to make it
all make sense and it's like this big
ten year running series of stories you
know in order to follow what it is that
one single character is doing and that's
that's the the biggest that's the bane
of models existence right now you know
and so I think going with
character-driven stories to say like if
all you care about is Peter Parker read
this if all you care about is miles well
let's read this you know if all you care
about is a Punisher or Captain America
or tony stark or something like that
that's why I think the superior iron man
did so well because if all you cared
about was iron man and you wanted to see
a comic book version of iron man from
the Marvel Cinematic Universe pick up
superior iron man and that's all you had
to read you could literally start with
superior man number one and go from
there it cover the event of access it
told you what happened in axis so you
can you match to read access you're
going to say well there's an aversion of
personalities and now he's a jerk so I
guess back to his old self whatever the
case may be but
that I think was a was a very important
attribute so I'm very much down with
doing characters but how do you feel
about them being shorter that's my big
purse oh okay no I think that's good
well no I mean we've I mean in the
character driven I didn't stop you
because that you make browser some very
good points but I'm saying cuz it feels
to me like story arcs in general are
getting shorter and shorter and shorter
I just finished a bunch of the dcu
storylines and it was two to three
issues long and they were done ya know
that makes sense because you're talking
about people like people's attention
spans are inherently shorter now than
they were before if we were talking
about 50 years ago 30 years ago i'd say
that's a really bad idea because people
liked longer and more you know
complicated stories and if you're
talking about massive crossover events
and yeah sure they can be longer but in
truth there's really no reason why you
know a character like the punisher needs
to have a 20 or 30 issue character story
arc it just doesn't need to happen you
know because it this long it draws out
it takes too long and that's a problem
that people feel you know people go
through and they read these stories and
they're just like god they're just
dragging on and dragging on a dragon on
and it feels like ninety percent of the
stories like ninety percent of that
story it's just filler stuff so I think
they're doing like two to three issues
stories is a much better decision I mean
it interests me a whole lot more you
know and plus yeah like that's what I
mean that makes our jobs easier it's a
lot easier to tell a story when it's 2
t-3 issues along especially especially
when we tell a 223 issue story and then
it's a lot easier to get people into the
stories now because the arc is done hey
go check out the next one yeah exactly I
agree with that I heard that someone's
been asking over and over and over I
guess they liked my professor xvideo
admit but didn't know his history and
they want to know what you think about
the idea of making a professor x solo
problem making a professor x solo comic
well it is he's old history when he was
in a venture yeah yeah uh I guess you
could but it doesn't I mean he doesn't
really matter I mean it's it's okay guys
I haven't seen you professor x video so
I'm not sure what all you covered but
here's literally the story of Professor
X alright professor X's dad worked
alongside a guy and professor X's dad
died in the experiment and I think it
turned out that the guy actually killed
his dad on purpose but nonetheless
microphone like this guy marries
professor X's mom brings along Cain
Marko Cain mark was a dick to Professor
X and this guy loves Professor X but
only because he wants to stay on good
terms with his mom professor X's mom
dies this guy inherits everything and
all that kind of good stuff and that he
dies Professor X inherits everything
Professor X you know develops powers
over the course of this time frame he
goes on to meet um oh god what was that
guy's name somewhere really spot-on for
an off the cuff off your head thank you
so he said she didn't watch my video he
goes on to meet umm al like Farouk so I
can't what his name is but he's
basically the Shadow King and like they
fight each other and then like they have
a mental fight you know with one another
and he's like oh my god this guy's
dangerous I better form a team that can
like keep the planet safe from dangerous
mutants and he makes the x-men and
that's the life of Professor Xavier
skipped a whole bunch of stuff in the
middle but like what were you meet to
magneto know when you use magneto goes
at a bunch of adventures he scours the
globe looking for mutants before
realizing loss to build the team yeah
but see the problem depends that depends
on which version of the story you're
looking at because if you go old enough
it's like oh you is a crazy adventurer
yeah okay i would i would say this it
depends on how they do it I think that
something like that would make a better
film than it would a comic book but it'd
be intriguing that the problem is we
know about everybody like we know their
stories now if we didn't know who they
were if we didn't know their backstories
it would make sense if we didn't know
the origin story of storm it would make
sense if we didn't know the origin story
of Banshee if we didn't know the origin
story of
and Jubilee and Cyclops and Jean Grey
all that kind of stuff then it would
make sense you know but the problem is
God all right but the problem is we know
those stories and so it really wouldn't
i wouldn't buy it to be honest i'm avery
manga other than DBZ i don't think you
have read the NZ not only the DBZ manga
just watch TV show but I say you don't
you don't rename on this dude no not
really in our defense we already get a
lot of comics like I bought that's what
I went out and I bought a six different
manga to read on my trip and I'm like I
hope that time that you really don't
because it got also on my trip is like
20 trade paperbacks for DC normal yeah
oh um with Nintendo entering Oh with
Anton is entering the theme park
business which game series would you
like to see uh come to life Kirby I
would love this is gonna be a restaurant
I could tato I know Kirby needs to be
like a big bouncy machine like it would
be so amazing you know like I would do
they need to have like a Kirby a curvy
themed ride in some capacity like I'd be
so down to see I don't care what it is
but i'd be down to see it like a white
ranger or green ranger I know it's Tommy
but whiskey before a green ranger wyd
ranger nothing dude green rangers uh
when green ranger first show dubbed he
single-handedly demolished all of the
Power Rangers by himself just him
demolish every else had a giant dragons
or but yes he did yes he did like it was
pretty solid they forgot this whole
video done while chatting with you who
is smarter Brainiac or the Kree supreme
intelligence ooh that is a tough one um
you for a second side I can't hear you
it's fun Brainiac or the Kree supreme
intelligence Jesus um
but guessing the Kree supreme
intelligence has the entire like man i
don't know i would say Brainiac I think
brainiacs more intelligent and here's a
reason why the Kree supreme intelligence
which for those of you guys who don't
know the Kree supreme intelligence is
like the ultimate authority and the Kree
Empire itself and the Kree supreme
intelligence is composed of the brains
of every Creed is ever existed the
problem is that their experiences like
the intelligence of the supreme
intelligence is confined to the
experiences of those Kree and so if
those crew only existed within their own
continuity or within the own own place
if they never branched out into other
worlds or anything like that then it's
going to limit the capacity of the
supreme intelligence now it doesn't and
the supreme intelligence is super smart
but I think that on a whole Brainiac is
far more intelligent and far more
capable because I've a brainiac bringing
acts intelligent on like a multiversal
level isn't he or something like that I
guess what passes for a multiverse 11
had so much version because there's so
many to immerse them there is one that's
multiversal there's one that's just
local which one you talked about yeah
yeah and that's the problem Brainiac
like they spent sums that are simple
there's been some that can see in peered
into the multiverse Dismas some that's
been a computer some that's been a being
it's yeah that's a good point it's one
thing i hate about Brainiac is like they
just alter him away to be cool he was
this way though that is true let's see
the most accepted version is the one
from the TV show though the one that
took over Lex Luthor's body that was a
cool version that one was pretty some
people grew up with that version so it
makes sense of people would suddenly not
device why it's most accepted yeah um
what do you dislike about the MCU ooh
what do I just like okay let's start
with you what are you just like about
the MCU Vinnie the TV shows I feel like
the TV shows have a lot more potential
they didn't have to wait for stuff to
happen in the movies I feel like it's
holding them back yes I know agents of
shield ins a lot of filler episodes just
to make a tie into civil war and tie
into the fall of shield and I like that
you see I agree with that i think that
them see i agree that the problem is
this like
this like the Inhumans theme was a
really cool theme going with the show
the problem is that by the time by the
time age of Ultron came around they
couldn't ignore it they couldn't just be
like well age of Ultron is going on
we're not worried about we're not
worried about a robot like you're like
trying to kill everybody on the world so
they couldn't just ignore it and keep
going with the Inhumans it wouldn't make
any sense and so they had to stop it you
know and then of course the next season
is going to follow up with it so I think
that is kind of a kind of a restraint
that's why that's why I personally like
the DC TV shows more and why I agree
with them saying goes they're going to
be separate continuities because that
means the DVD see shows can do whatever
the hell they want if the flash wants to
jump through time and gonna mess with
the world that doesn't affect the movies
see that is a good point but i like that
i like them I like I prefer Marvel
because I think it makes a more cohesive
thing everything ties and everything
else and I like it I mean it has us
restrictions but I think the fact that
everything tides and everything else
having said that I think happening that
both is the great because I do like
having a melt I in I think it hinders
the show but having having marble do
that and then having deceived you a
different thing allows you to appreciate
what DC is able to do and at the same
time appreciate tying the show into this
overarching thing and feeling cool
because you washed everything and no at
all that's true that is a good point i
would say that when it comes to the to
the MCU one of the things that i don't
like is that things feel so isolated i
mean it is cohesive but it's isolated at
the same time there's earthbound stuff
and their space stuff and we know that
Thanos is in the background we know he's
gathering the Infinity stones and the
Infinity stones have been featured in
both guardians of the galaxy and
Avengers and other films and stuff like
that but at the same time it doesn't
feel connected like it feels it as
opposed to as opposed to like two hands
you know like intertwined it feels like
fingers touching and it just like it's a
loose connection and it just doesn't
quite feel as cohesive as I could now
infinity where we'll fix that and it'll
bring everything together you know it'll
have the Avengers it'll have the
guardians of the galaxy and all that
kind of stuff fighting Thanos but until
that point it just doesn't feel
connected
all you know and it's cool seeing you
know stuff cross over to school seeing
people mentioned you know but I think
that's one reason ask you this we all
love daredevil I mean I know I know I
took forever to finally watch at all but
we all love daredevil right there
doubled in time to crap in 2d stripes
well that's I was going to say like that
was a problem with daredevil as
daredevil was a story word featured a
guy that we know is in the MCU and we
know nothing like we we see nothing else
tying it in it's literally posters and
newspaper clippings and that's it but
that's what I was also about see I
disagree like I think it would have been
cool if I mean we wouldn't necessarily
have to see characters but if they had
like like well they didn't have they
didn't have any footage of the Avengers
fighting in New York did there so you'd
have been different if they had that if
like on the background TV you know or
something like that there was like like
you know there was somebody looking
through old footage and they were
watching The Avengers fighting in New
York that I think like that right there
it could have been a 10 second thing
we're five-second thing for that matter
and I think it would have made the thing
made it work out made it more cohesive
but right now it feels so isolated that
it doesn't even feel like it's part of
the MCU we know what is it just doesn't
feel like it is and that's that I think
it's kind of a kind of the rough patch
but you know I mean it's were those
weird things I guess no prob i don't
know it's my name how much of it daily
haha how can my god Manny sound like it
sound like one of the hardcore fans of
my gentleman Rob I really would have
liked it if you'd have gone more
in-depth into this hour long video i
really i missed the hour long video job
even though they take forever you can
yet you can't produce them in a quick
matter i really miss the hour-long
videos yeah like that like me and me and
three other people really miss these
video so you need to go back to make a
thumbs like ignore if you're like an
imax unit because i'm doing that like
you a vlog thing now on every tuesday
right it's at three big questions and
i'm going to address the fact that my
videos have been getting shorter there's
nothing to do with me and I know you're
running into the same issue it's because
a lot of the newer characters don't have
a lot of information or the story or
it's a shorter yeah and that's it that's
all there is to it Rob a few if you
could have that why you got some sense
to the power rangers 0 power so good if
you could have the powers and abilities
of any of the original seven Justice
League membership who would you choose I
just saw
it's not the other day said Power
Rangers Wow if I can have the powers of
any of the original Justice League so
you're talking about Golden Age like
old-school justice league well okay are
you talk about justice society or you
talking about justice league because
justice league with silver age just
society was golden age hmm the southern
original members of the Justice League
probably everybody feel about Linkara
Cruz Linkara sandy you're gonna say why
don't I read the chat what do you think
I'm doing anything i miss you think I'm
just making up questions off the top of
my head in the nan Serena and you're
really good back I'm really good either
present huh that person has no idea
what's going on next season will be
shooting wars just live and he's trying
to do the e strategies more those guys
that shows up later and is likewise drop
another three he does not live yeah like
it's funny cuz I'll see that from time
to time like somebody i post a comment
like the video wolf little it'll go live
on youtube like it'll it'll upload when
it's done and somebody will be like it's
still going on it's like yes it's still
going on that's why i always posting my
concluded makes realize that question
i'll change the title to concluded let
still say that like why do you not
answer my questions like because it's
not having anymore because it's done um
let's see is it comfortable to have that
strap on your head it's not a strap the
headphones it's the shape of the
headphones let's see are they redoing
blade on netflix i don't think so what
happened to secret war secret war just a
monthly serious guys it comes up once a
month then what's not you really think
that's that up right okay it was fun to
a problem I everyone's asking is because
it came one two three back to back and
then they delayed it for a month came
out for delayed it five yeah that's true
I agree with it yeah the next one comes
out in three weeks I think so if you
were to be any superhero either Marvel
or DC who would you be Marvel or DC
spite of it now spider-man sucks
my god man madness this is madness
robbie can't state you're like half the
chats gonna leave now um well you really
did he dropped in half the numbers not
oh my god what happened we drop it to
other people um cara the weekly poll we
could try to see that happening for the
record Linkara is do you know the guy
with the glasses nostalgic critic no
he's a he's pretty much like the angry
video game nerd for that error of
YouTube a kilometer of like tons of
reviewers to various things like angry
Joe is his video game review originally
now penkridge odessa's own thing okay
think Cara is technically the comic
review okay okay if I could you review
some of the worst comic sans this is
that that's his job like he would but he
who pull up some things in like 1970s
okay with what oh did you find that um
if I could be any character from Marvel
or DC any superhero huh I would be Kyle
Rayner and here's why because too
becomes face Jesus because it becomes
face Jesus done and done he becomes
space Jesus I am gonna make a video
about apologies about kyle rayner I'm
gonna call it kyle rayner / space Jesus
if you don't believe you read his
features and it is full beard and he has
faced you this it is horrifying planet
it hatches on the white ring while
sacrificing his life of a spacious yeah
space Jesus space to use this kyle
rayner you know i'm gonna ask your
audience lling because i need i need to
know they want me to do which way they
want me to spawn I'm sure they want you
to too but in order for us to do that
where is Al Simmons new origin when did
he come back because that's where I'm
gonna start if I do it yeah that was a
good place to start we would like well
we should you spot I guys I don't know
about Rob but I'm not doing 200 issues a
spot no I'm not hell no and you're out
of your mind you think it's gonna happen
that's what I mean Tyrone Magnus on the
weekly pool
little magma sides let's see Rob do you
watch fan films on YouTube a black
panther unleashed just great yes
actually there was that there was a
really good one for the century it was a
really cool fan film but I yeah I
watched those occasion there was
actually a fan film that was made I
think about spider-man where he's
approached by shield and that was a
really cool video it was only like 10
minutes long but it was really
interesting see he wanted to break them
back every week now Rob do Anna you have
to call me every week this early in the
morning yay do you think Lars will make
it into the MCU in any way she seems to
be the only one missing from Magneto's
kids then no polaris doesn't matter
enough she's not important i starve
interrupting I know shushing I'm sorry
about doing that this time over here if
you want me on Tuesdays I do is
interrupt you but mmm yeah if you guys
watch this on the weekly pull on Tuesday
I want actually this opinion this cuz
after seeing what they've done with
quicks over in Scotland where they're
going with them I honestly feel like
that was literally just marble putting a
stab at Fox like I don't think they did
it with a oh we got to see what's going
on you know uh-oh by just saying like
they're in humans and they're not just
putting him in the movie and then just
removing it basically willing to remove
them in the Scarlet Witch is coming back
there's a new Avenger but Quicksilver
yeah they could have done without how
important is she you know yeah that's
true um man that's a good question uh I
mean I wouldn't put it past with how
petty the robberies have gotten between
all these companies owning marbles
characters Disney really being like to
put a minute we can do it do it I'm
freaking care i would say that yeah i
mean it might be a stab at it might be a
stab at fox um but I mean Fox needs no
help and stabbing themselves so but uh
but no I mean it's it's yeah because
here's here's the kicker they could have
kept Quicksilver alive they didn't need
to kill him in fact in essence eyeing
him dying was really one of the silliest
sand most unexplained things in the film
like how good a guy that moves that fast
die by bullets
and and they were like really jumped at
this like the guy can move super fast
you're telling me that he couldn't run
you know push robert downey jr who ever
you know in front of that if I whatever
push him to safety in front of the
vehicle and then get out of the way
before the bullets hit him but no way
you know not even that they pretty much
established that uh they pretty much let
Fox have a more powerful version if it's
over yeah because he's stupid powerful
and days of future past he's really fast
like it's nuts how fast he is annie's
actually that's the date of future past
was actually accurate in terms of his
speed at least in terms of how they
depicted it with with Avengers 2 age of
Ultron he was actually seemed slower
than he was supposed to be it was just
one of the big drawbacks that I had I
was like he'd smoothing kind of slow you
know but but nonetheless no I would say
that that's probably a stab at Fox to
like introduce a character and then kill
them off you know but uh no I don't know
I mean it's weird but anyway guys um
we've been cranking it this for like an
hour so I ask you how long do you do
this for cuz I got a good things about
now in 15 minutes yeah so I'm going to
bounce off here guys but say thank you
everybody to bidding you for coming in
and saying what's up what's up God